[Music]
that were shot came from that's where
shook came from right huh could I look
who are obnoxious yes I could hi guys my
name is grace Helbig if you do not know
now you know your life is different now
my dog left the room she's embarrassed
this is a stream-of-consciousness video
if you're unfamiliar occasionally I do
stream-of-consciousness videos more
often recently that are just verbalizing
the streams of consciousness I have in
my brain anyone else think about TLC
jump up to some waterfalls and hear the
word stream yeah how was your Halloween
was it fun I hope it was fun I lost my
keys I lost my keys I lost my keys I
lost my keys I was in bed by 9 p.m. and
then got a text from a good friend some
of you might know of her her name is
Mary Hart sang she was back in town
and so we both put on our cop-con
onesies and went out and twelve hours
later I woke up in my bed without my
keys and it is a wildly vulnerable
experience not having your keys if
you've never experienced it before it's
one of those really humanizing moments
you know to err is human to err err is
human to make mistakes to falter to fail
is human and it truly is I feel like
such a dumb human right so I hope that
your Halloween was a little bit more
pleasant my Halloween is super fun this
is the byproduct of my Halloween is not
super fun but is look like what is this
who is it am I allowed to be a human
okay to err is human there's a lot of
air happening right now now it's
November that's exciting Thanksgiving is
not acknowledged by any convenience
store it's all Christmas Christmas
critics giving must feel so
self-conscious Thanksgiving must feel
like the middle child between Halloween
and Christmas
Christmas is the baby psyche so
attention-seeking and everyone loves
Halloween is the oldest sibling it's the
one that's like crazy and wild it does
all the stuff that's really like dumb
and stupid so that you learn a watching
than fail watching me feel where my
[ __ ] keys
raise your hands if you voted already
that's a good look if you haven't don't
forget November 8th you can vote what's
happening with the world I look at
Twitter moments for a moment in time
because that's how I learn about the
world and stuff in life men abandoned
birth control study citing side-effects
that doesn't seem like a headline that's
light and fun o bono to finally be
awarded woman of the year what what this
is okay this is real right we're not
collectively having a giant fever dream
youtube frontman and human rights
advocate Bono has made glamorous annual
women of the year list unsurprisingly
the announcement hasn't gone down all
that well what and why and also what and
then follow-up question why here's
another fun piece of gender specific
news women will never be priests Pope
Francis says the Roman Catholic Church's
ban on female priests will likely last
forever hiding to here on the ordination
of women in the Catholic Church the last
word is clear the Pope told reporters
Tuesday he referred to a letter by Pope
John Paul the second that affirmed Jesus
chose only men as his apostles I'd to
hear someone loves that hilarious piece
of fiction so Jesus one chose men to be
as apostles he also only chose to wear
dresses with a cinch waist I don't see
any photos of him in jeans
so thank you Twitter moments for that
brief indulgence into culture in the
world what's going on you guys
anything exciting cool enthusiasm made
me tired hey let's find out what daily
holiday it is how about that that's a
fun thing for us to learn together
yeah Oh guys this is a good one it's my
leg day
to quote days of the year calm there are
many ways to prepare eggs or one of the
most delicious
is to make them into deviled eggs if you
haven't tried this method before the
perfect day to start is deviled egg day
the other major holiday that we were all
celebrating today it's stress Awareness
Day are you stressed out are you aware
of it
happy holidays who decided that what
group of human beings set sorry my time
is up thank you and good night do it
tomorrow is guess we got to get ahead of
these holidays November third is family
fish day international project
management day ha ha ha sorry
tomorrow is men make dinner day and this
is a photo that days of the year calm
has chosen 2 years to celebrate and then
Nick dinner day I mean that's very
festive get ready guys there's a lot to
celebrate in life lots of highs lots of
low lows if you find my keys please let
me know that's it I know that this seems
nonsensical and dumb but that's every
video that I make on this channel and
you can get updated about every video
that gets uploaded to the channel by
subscribing to this channel by clicking
that button if this video thumbs up so I
know that you enjoyed this on any level
good luck with your stress it's ok today
is a day to celebrate it like could I be
more of a poster child for like stress
that's it
I don't know also oh there's that oh
sorry
addendum to that